près de 160 coureurs ont répondu à
l'invitation de special olympics
c'est la huitième course solidaire
interentreprises de l'association le but
est de courir angolais est de
sensibiliser au handicap mental vous
regarde jours à ce que c'est à la portée
de tous nos qu'un une bonne action à un
réflexe est encore mieux on a créé des
initiatives en faveur des
des populations ont justement handicapé
depuis quelques temps d'arracher les os
et donc on reste associé cette cause
depuis c'est important pour nous est
vraiment ça prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur le handicap psychique et moins
connus donc l'objectif est double
aujourd'hui nous faire connaître sur
bassin d'emploi mais aussi communiquer
ensuite en interne sur le handicap
psychique 1 en france 700 mille
personnes vivant avec un handicap mental
l'association spécial olympics organise
chaque année des courses où se côtoient
tous les publics
en plus des entreprises on a trois
établissements qui sont présents
l'établissement des mesnuls la roseraie
et l'alph et qui viennent courir aux
côtés des salariés je pense que c'est ça
qui est important c'est que les salariés
des entreprises soit aux côtés des
personnes en situation de handicap
mental
puisque c'est aussi ça l'objectif de
notre association changer le regard de
la société avec cette édition
l'association a récolté plus de 15000
euros
ces fonds serviront à organiser des
événements sportifs à destination de
personnes en situation de handicap
mental